AWAY FROM A POSSIBLE SECOND
GOVERNMENT SHUT DOWN MAY BE OF
THE NEW YEAR.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL'S ON
CAPITOL HILL WITH A STATUS
REPORT.
>> HOUSE REPUBLICANS WILL MEET
TO DISCUSS FUNDING THE
SOURCES TELL FOX A SIX WEEK
EXTENSION THROUGH MARCH 22ND IS
LIKELY.
DEMOCRATS HAVE NOT AGREED TO A
SPENDING CAP DEAL.
ONE OPTION IS ADDING MORE
NATIONAL SECURITY MONEY TO WIN
OVER DEFENSE HAWKS.
>> NO REASON WHY OUR WAR
FIGHTERS NEED TO CONTINUE TO
FACE UNCERTAINTY UNTIL ALL THE
OTHER ISSUES ARE RESOLVED.
>> THE IDEA IS NOT PLACATING THE
DEMOCRATS SENATE LEADER.
>> THERE ISN'T MUCH TIME TO
WASTE.
AND YET SPEAKER RYAN IS
CONSIDERING A SHORT-TERM
EXTENSION OF FUNDING FOR URGENT
DOMESTIC PRIORITIES BUT A
>> SPEAKER RYAN SAID LAWMAKERS
WERE MAKING PROGRESS ON SETTING
SPENDING LEVELS BUT NEEDED MORE
TIME.
AFTER A BRIEF SHUTDOWN IN
JANUARY OVER DACA, THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE BROUGHT TO THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY BY THE PARENTS,
DEMOCRATS DON'T SOUND EAGER TO
SHUTDOWN COMING BUT I SEE A
PROMISE BY SENATOR McCONNELL
TO FINALLY BRING THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE THAT AFFECTS THE LIVES OF
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
IN AMERICA, FINALLY BRINGING IT
TO A FULL DEBATE IN THE SENATE.
>> SENATORS JOHN McCAIN AND
CHRIS COONS OFFERED A BIPARTISAN
IMMIGRATION PLAN.
THE WHITE HOUSE WAS QUICK TO
REJECT IT BECAUSE IT DOES NOT
PROVIDE MONEY FOR THE BORDER
WALL AND DOES NOT END CHAIN
MIGRATION OR THE DIVERSITY VISA
PROGRAM.
>> THESE TWO PROGRAMS RISK
EXPLOITATION FROM THOSE WHO DO
NOT SHARE OUR VALUES AND
ACTIVELY WORK TO UNDERMINE THEM.
>> SENATOR COONS CALLED IT A
GOOD STARTING PROPOSAL FOR A
DEBATE.
>> LAYS OUT A PLAN HALFWAY
TOWARD SECURING CONTROL OF THE
BORDER BY 2020.
>> REPUBLICANS NOTE
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE A SERIOUS
OFFER INCLUDING A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR 1.8 MILLION
PEOPLE AND DEMOCRATS MUST DECIDE
IF THEY WANT A SOLUTION OR
CAMPAIGN ISSUE.
>> I HOPE THERE IS A DEAL, GET
IT OFF THE TABLE.
IF THE DEMOCRATS TURN IT DOWN,
IT SHOULD BE AN ISSUE AGAINST
EXTENDING HEALTH CARE SPENDING
SUCH AS COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE